♪ (music) ♪
Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to I/O!
(cheers and applause)
For about a third of you here live,
this is your first I/O.
And it's mine, too.
(cheers and applause)
I'm so glad to be here with you, live,
and to welcome all of those on livestream.
You know, we have developers here
from 120 countries around the world,
and many of you watching us
from around the world.
Thank you for taking the time.
(cheers and applause)
Thank you for making time,
no matter what time it is where you are,
to invest in yourself, your knowledge,
and to spend time with us
as we tell you what we're super excited
about showing you today.
Many of you are connected
through our developer community groups.
You know, we have almost 1,000
Google developer groups around the world.
And if you're one
of our Google developer experts,
each of you do so much
to help your local developer community
learn and grow with Google.
We appreciate everything you do for us.
(cheers and applause)
You know, we each have
our own unique paths
to becoming developers.
Some of you here are students,
and just by being here
you've got a leg up
on your paths to learning.
When I was in college,
my first job was
in the Computer Science Lab,
learning to program the first
3D graphical visualization library
for gaming and entertainment software
on a Silicon Graphics IRIS workstation.
Developing that visualization library
was so magical,
because people could create amazing
special effects with it so quickly.
And, even though
I'd never programmed before then,
I felt confident that,
with the cutting-edge tools
and some helpful friends,
I could do it, I could figure it out.
And that's the feeling
we want each of you to have today,
and every day,
that anything is possible,
and that you can create
that next amazing experience,
app, or startup.
There's never been
a better time to be a developer.
There are three important reasons
that I believe this is true.
First, new user interfaces
such as voice, camera, speech,
are making computing ambient,
available to humans
wherever they are, all the time,
and enabling much richer
forms of interaction
than were possible
through keyboards and mice.
Second, as you heard this morning,
the Assistant provides great facilities
to make computing much more helpful
and convenient for people.
And third, with the advent
of cloud computing,
we offer incredibly effective tools
for developers,
whether that's the convenience
of serverless and container technology
or the ability to infuse
artificial intelligence
and machine learning
into your applications.
Now, Google was founded by developers,
and we're made up
of engineers and developers.
Our engineers work hard
to bring you new platforms and APIs
so that you can get your idea
and your passion
in front of billions of users,
including the next billion to come
from around the world.
We give you an opportunity
to see how far your ideas can go,
and we're grateful to play a role in this.
With this opportunity
also comes responsibility.
Each of us shares
a responsibility to our users
to make good things for them,
to be advocates for them,
to respect them, to help them,
to delight them
with what you build
with your creativity and passion.
We at Google have a responsibility
to you, the developer community.
We seek to empower you
with the technology and tools
to help you build, grow,
to learn, and to earn.
And that's exactly
what we're here to do today.
We're going to spend the next hour
sharing an awesome set of updates
from our developer teams at Google,
who are working to enable
and support you on your unique path,
whether that's the latest advances
in our Assistant,
machine learning, Android, web, and more.
We have a fantastic show planned for you.
To get started, I'd like to welcome Chet
to share the latest from Android.
♪ (music) ♪
(cheers and applause)
We heard in the earlier keynote
about the amazing ecosystem
that Android has become.
I want to focus on two aspects
of that ecosystem.
One is that Android is a product
that brings rich experiences to users--
that's all of you--
all over the world.
The other is that Android
is also a platform
that brings capabilities to developers--
that's also all of you--
to build powerful applications.
So today I'm going to talk
about the things that we're doing
to ensure the users
can have a product that they trust
while developers become
more productive with our platform.
So, first, let's talk
about responsibility to our users.
As a developer community,
we all care about getting this right.
It's about building a platform
that gives developers
powerful capabilities
while making sure that users feel
that their safety
and privacy is protected.
When we released Android Q Beta
a few months ago,
we had nearly 50 features and improvements
that were all about giving users
more control and transparency
over their experience.
But some of those changes
required more effort from you,
the developers for the platform.
A good example of that
is the changes in storage.
We got strong feedback from you
in the Beta 1 and Beta 2 releases
that helped us find a better way.
So you'll see
in the Beta 2.5 and 3 releases
that we have a new approach
that reflects the input
that we got from you
and makes it easier to adopt
to those changes going forward.
So thank you for the feedback,
and please keep it coming.
This is actually exactly
why we do preview releases,
because we want to iterate with you
to find the best solution for everybody
before the final release.
It's why we do previews,
and it's also why we love
our developer community.
Speaking of developers,
let's talk about developer productivity.
We care about productivity for developers.
In fact, we care deeply
about productivity for developers,
because we are all developers, as well.
And we know
that the more productive we are,
the more code we get to write.
So, two years ago, we announced Kotlin
as a supported language for Android.
Many developers were using Kotlin already,
and many more have been using it since.
In fact, over 50%
of our pro developers are using it,
and it's the fastest growing
language on GitHub.
It's production ready,
and it's being used by top apps
both inside and outside of Google.
One of the concerns that we have, though,
is that developers' typing skills
are eroding
without the need
for so much boilerplate code.
(cheers and applause)
In fact, developers are so desperate
for finger exercise
that they're actually starting
to comment their Kotlin code.
(laughter)
A little.
But you've asked us
to do even more for Kotlin,
so we're announcing today a big step.
Android is becoming
increasingly Kotlin-first,
with many new Jetpack APIs
being introduced first
for Kotlin developers.
(cheers and applause)
We also think that if you have
a new project that you're starting
that you should be doing it in Kotlin,
because, frankly, there's less to type,
there's less to test,
and there's less to maintain.
We're also investing much more
in tooling, in docs, and in training.
For example, together with JetBrains,
we're announcing Kotlin/Everywhere,
which is a global series
of educational events.
But maybe you're using
one of Android's two other
officially-supported languages,
C++ or the Java programming language.
That's fine.
We continue to support these languages,
and we continue to invest in them.
For example, we have
a new toolchain for C++.
On the Java side,
we're offering desugaring
for language features up through Java 10,
and soon you'll see desugaring
for popular OpenJDK libraries
like Time and Streams.
So you can keep using those languages
if they're using them,
and trust that we will keep
supporting them.
We have always been committed on Android
to compatibility, interoperability
and our ecosystem,
and that is not changing.
Last year we announced Android Jetpack,
which is a set of APIs to accelerate
Android application development.
We've had great adoption so far,
with 80% of the top 1,000 apps
shipping with Jetpack modules.
Jetpack is all about typing less code
to target a larger audience,
because we support releases
all the way back to API 14.
It builds on the capabilities
that we already had
with a support library,
adds in what we had introduced
with the Architecture Components,
and we just keep introducing
new APIs and libraries as we go.
I'm going to talk about
three new developments in Jetpack today--
a new Camera library,
some new Architecture Components,
and a brief glimpse into something
brand new we're working on.
So today we're launching CameraX.
It's a library to make Camera
application development
much more easy and consistent
across 90%
of the Android devices out there.
A few years ago,
I was talking to a couple of engineers
from a company that was working
on an interesting photo app.
It took great pictures,
it did all these interesting
filtering effects,
but they had a problem.
Some of the devices the users had
didn't run their application correctly
without workarounds in their code.
It was because of inconsistent support
for some of the platform APIs.
So here's how CameraX helps.
It works on releases
all the way back to Lollipop,
and it can take those workarounds
and put it in the library itself.
So you call one API,
and it figures how to make it work
on the runtime device.
And it does that with more concise APIs
for core use cases,
so that your code can be smaller.
And, finally, it adds
an extension add-on feature,
which can access
device-specific functionality
like HDR, or night mode, or portrait mode.
We're working with several manufacturers
on the extensions right now,
and you'll soon see Extensions coming out
for both new and existing devices.
Architecture Components came out
a couple of years ago,
specifically to address
serious pain points
in Android development.
It also works, like the rest of Jetpack,
across versions
all the way back to API level 14.
We've had a couple of components
that we introduced last year at I/O
that recently went 1.0.
One of those is WorkManager,
for easier simplification
of background job scheduling.
The other is Navigation Controller,
for easier creation and editing
of in-app navigation.
We're also doing new work
on existing components,
such as RxJava
and coroutine support in Room,
as well as, for Kotlin developers,
deep integration of coroutines
into the Lifecycle and LiveData modules.
And we're working on new components.
We announced SavedState for ViewModel,
which allows easier processing
of application or process restarts,
and we also have a new Jetpack module
for benchmarking
which allows much easier
performance testing
of your application code.
And there's one more thing I want
to mention about Kotlin development.
We know that many of you
have been wanting
a modern reactive-style UI toolkit,
one that takes advantage of Kotlin
and also integrates with the platform code
as well as all of your existing
application code.
We've been working hard
on a Kotlin-first library
that we call Jetpack Compose.
It's a reactive
UI-programming library that's...
We are proud to announce today
we will be developing in the open in AOSP.
And that's...
Sure, sure, you can do that.
(cheers and applause)
So you can check that out starting today.
And this is just a brief tease.
If you want to know more about that,
attend the "What's New In Android" session
which immediately follows this keynote.
So just stay in your seats
and you'll learn more.
Android Studio launched five years ago.
Since then they've had
a lot of great features come out
like ConstraintLayout editing,
lots of profilers, static analysis,
lots of great Kotlin support.
But we heard from you
that some of the fundamentals
didn't work well enough for you,
and it could be really frustrating.
So we had to revisit some of the basics.
The entire team, for the last six months,
has stopped feature development completely
to focus exclusively on quality,
to make the core tool better.
(cheers and applause)
They've fixed over 400
high-priority bugs--
things like crashes
and performance problems,
UI freezes, memory leaks,
and we're always working
on build speed as well.
We've also taken another run
at some features
to make them work better,
such as Instant Run.
We heard from you
that it was great when it worked,
it wasn't reliable enough,
so we've rewritten that completely
from the ground up
with a much more stable foundation,
and it's now called Apply Changes.
The best part about
all the quality work in Studio
is it's available today.
3.5 Beta launches today,
so you can go download it and play with it
as soon as I'm done talking.
(cheers and applause)
So having an application is great,
but getting it out
to your users, even better.
So let's talk about distribution.
We introduced
Android App Bundles last year,
and now there's
80,000 applications shipping
with this new bundling format.
And they're getting an average
APK size savings of about 20%.
Another thing that helps with size
is Dynamic Feature Modules,
which was in beta
and is going 1.0 this week.
This allows you to choose the features
that are downloaded onto a device,
such as device-specific capabilities,
or country information,
or on-demand versus install-time features.
But both of these things
are not just about size,
they're about the development
and distribution process.
It's much more modular,
and it scales with team sizes much better.
So if you haven't looked into them yet,
we think that you should.
There's one last area in distribution
I want to talk about.
It's in-app updates.
You've asked us
for this feature for a while.
It's the ability to have
a really important bug
that needs to be fixed--
let's say there's a security problem,
or an in-app billing
that's affecting monetization,
or maybe you just have
a really cool button
that you want to put in the UI--
and you want to make sure
that your users get this update
as soon as possible,
without waiting for them
to get to the Play Store
and see that there's an update available.
That capability is available now,
and Tor is going to show you how it works.
(Tor Norbye) Thanks, Chet.
So, the in-app update functionality
is now part of the Play Core library
and is available
for all of you to use right away.
But we've also started working
on a Kotlin and Jetpack API
to make it simpler to use,
and that's what I'm going to show you now.
So here I'm developing
the Google I/O Conference app,
and I'm going to open up my Activity.
And in the onCreate method
I'm going to call
a single extension method,
updateIfRequired()
and invoke Apply Changes.
In advance, I've already uploaded
a higher version of my app
to the Play Store
to simulate a future update.
And, as you can see,
now when users run my app
they get this full-screen prompt
asking them to update right away.
And note that I only had to add
a single line of code to do that.
But this also means
that every single update,
even a minor one, will show this UI,
and your users may not be
really thrilled about that,
So we can make the update check smarter.
We can pass in a lambda
where we look at the offered version code
and decide whether to show
the full-screen prompt.
So that way, in the future,
for each update you can choose
whether to trigger the prompt
by setting the right bits
in the version code.
So now I've restarted my app,
and this update did not request
an immediate prompt
so we're back in our Activity.
And notice that there's
an Update button here now.
That's something I added in advance.
This is our more flexible update API,
and here's the code for it.
I'm not going to explain this,
because this part depends a lot
on the surrounding app
you're integrating into.
But, as you can see,
it's not a lot of work or code.
So let's take a look
at what this lets you do,
the flexible update API.
So this Update button only shows up
if there's an update available.
As a user, I can click on it
to trigger an update.
That will then download in the background
while I can continue to use the app.
And, when it's done,
I have the option of restarting
when I am ready to.
Now, final important point.
You need to have the foresight
to put an update check
into your current version.
That's what will let you
push out an update to it later,
when you might need it.
(Chet Haase) Thanks, Tor.
(applause)
We had a really quick look today
at how we're making things better
for both users and developers,
as we all make Android
a better product and platform--
from privacy features,
to Kotlin, to Jetpack,
I really hope you enjoy
the things that we've put in our... Q.
(laughter)
Thank Q.
(laughter and applause)
So that is my Q to leave, but first...
One of the exciting things in Android
in the last couple of years
is the collaboration that we've had
with the Google Assistant.
Here to tell you more about the Assistant,
here's Chris Turkstra.
Thank you.
♪ (music) ♪
(Chris Turkstra) Thank you, Chet.
We believe technology is at its best
when it makes things simple,
and that's really
what the Google Assistant is all about.
The idea that you can simply
ask for what you want
without thinking
about all the steps involved
is a fundamental shift in the way
that people use technology.
And this isn't just an idea.
People all around the world
are using the Assistant every day
to get things done--
on their mobile devices,
in their cars,
and at home.
And in the smart home space alone,
there are more than 30,000 unique devices
that now work with the Google Assistant.
These are built by a growing community
of over 3,500 partners.
It's momentum like this
that creates lots of opportunities
for developers like you.
Today, I'll share new tools
for content creators and app developers
to build with the Assistant.
Let's start with what's new
for content creators.
We know you want easier ways
to reach more users
across all of Google,
and so we're introducing a simple way
to make your web content stand out
across both Google Search
and the Assistant,
using something you're already
familiar with: markup.
We're starting by enabling the support
for the HowTo item type from schema.org
so that your site's
how-to content can appear
in a rich, structured way.
Here's an example.
My kids are headed off to college soon,
so we're looking
for a kid-replacement unit,
also known as a dog.
(laughter)
So I've been trying to figure out
how to install a dog door.
Well, DIY Networks has an article on this,
and they've implemented markup,
identifying each step in their page.
So when I search for
"How to Install a Dog Door"
their content appears
as a more structured, helpful result.
You'll notice these step-by-step
visual instructions
on the search result page,
and they really stand out.
And the best part
is that the same simple markup
creates an interactive result
on its system-enabled smart displays.
This extends the reach of your content
to an entirely new surface
with no extra work.
In addition to instructional content
on web pages,
people also turn to YouTube every day
to learn how to do things.
So we're making it much easier
for video creators
to add content to the Assistant.
We're adding a new How-To Template
in the Actions console
where you can turn your existing videos
into interactive tutorials.
Let's take a look.
Here, REI filled out a How-To Template
with titles, text, and timestamps
for each step in their video
and uploaded it to the Actions console.
This transformed their video
into an interactive,
step-by-step experience
with very little work.
You can get started
with the HowTo Templates today.
Now let's talk about what's new
for app developers,
and I hear there might be
a few Android fans here in the audience.
(applause)
Thank you.
And we know you want to make it easier
for users to get into your apps.
So last year we previewed App Actions,
a way to create voice-based entry points
from the Assistant to exactly
the right spot in your app
using intents.
Today we're announcing
four categories of App Actions
that are ready to use--
Health & Fitness, Finance,
Ridesharing, and Food Ordering.
Let's look at Health & Fitness,
an area that I'm clearly new to.
(laughter)
Nike has a great app
that lets me track my runs,
but when my shoes are on,
my headphones are in,
and I'm finally ready
to actually take a run,
I don't want to tap through my phone
to get it all started.
Wouldn't it be much faster
if I could just use my voice?
Well, luckily,
Nike implemented App Actions,
so when I say, "Hey Google,
start my run with Nike Run Club,"
the Assistant fast forwards
into Nike's app
and automatically starts my run.
I didn't need to swipe, tap,
or navigate to find what I needed,
I simply asked.
Let's take a look at how they did it.
Here you can see Nike's
actions.xml file in their manifest
where they map
the START_EXERCISE built-in intent
to the part of their app
that starts a workout.
And with that change,
their redeploy, their APK,
and it's ready for action.
You can get started today
with the four live intent categories.
And we have more for app developers.
Smart displays have been
a huge hit for consumers.
And, for the first time ever,
we're opening up the ability
for app developers
to address the full display
of the smart display.
So we're introducing a developer preview
of Interactive Canvas,
a tool to create full-screen experiences
for smart displays
that leverage voice, visuals, and touch.
It uses open web technologies
you're already familiar with,
like HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
And we're starting
where interactive experiences
really come to life: games.
Here's an example of a trivia game--
it was built by HQ University
with Interactive Canvas--
that leverages the full-screen experience.
You can start building games today,
and we'd love to hear your feedback
as we consider which categories
to open up next.
Whether you're looking
to reach more users across Google
with your content,
drive more engagement with your apps,
or build custom experiences
for the Assistant,
you now have more tools to do so.
And now I'd like to introduce Tal,
who's going to talk more
about the web platform.
Thank you.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
(Tal Oppenheimer) Thanks, Chris.
The open web provides universal access
to the world's information and services
for billions of people
across the full spectrum of devices--
from entry-level phones,
to high-powered desktops.
With Chrome, we're focused
on providing the global community
with a modern,
continuously updated browser
with new releases every six weeks.
And we contribute our work
to the entire web ecosystem
with the open source Chromium project.
Today we're going to share
the latest improvements to Chrome
and our developer tools that you can use
to make your websites faster
and more powerful,
all while keeping user trust
front and center.
We all know that speed matters on the web,
and that even small improvements
can translate into big wins
for developers and for users.
So we're continuously working
to make the web faster.
One area that we focused on with Chrome
is reducing that startup time,
so that now, when you launch Chrome
on an entry-level Android phone,
the web page loads
in almost half the time.
And this speed-up is partly due
to improvements in V8,
our open source JavaScript engine.
It's now two times faster
at parsing JavaScript,
and uses up to 20% less memory
on real-world websites.
In addition to these improvements
in Chrome,
we're also adding features
to the web platform
to help you make your sites even faster.
As one example,
there's image lazy loading.
Modern websites are more visual than ever,
using lots of beautiful
high-resolution imagery.
But loading all those images at once
can bog down the browser
and can waste the user's data
by loading unnecessary images
that the user never actually sees.
So it's often better to load images
only as they're actually needed,
a technique known as lazy loading.
We know it can be a lot of work
for developers to use
their own JavaScript solutions,
and it can be hard to get
the quality experience
you want for your users.
So we wanted to make it incredibly simple
to have a great image-loading
experience on your site.
Starting behind a flag
in Chrome Canary today,
all you'll need to do is add
the new loading attribute
to your image tags, and Chrome
will take care of the rest.
(cheers and applause)
We'll take into account
factors like connection speed
to decide when to load the images,
and we'll check the first two kilobytes
of the deferred image
to add placeholders
that are the right size.
The end result
is a much smoother experience
for image-heavy sites,
all without the need
to write any extra code.
We've also been enhancing
our developer tools
to help you understand
how you can use all of these improvements.
Three years ago, we introduced Lighthouse,
a powerful tool that audits your website
and provides you with clear guidance
on how you can improve
your site's performance,
security, and lots more.
Lighthouse's reports have been used
to improve millions of web pages,
but because our websites,
and the web itself,
are constantly evolving,
auditing tools like Lighthouse
need to become
a continual part
of the development process.
And we're seeing that some developers
are already doing this.
At Pinterest, they've set
specific size limits
and performance thresholds for their site,
and continuously measure it
to ensure they aren't regressing.
They call these limits a "budget,"
and by optimizing for performance
and enforcing these budgets
they're able to ensure
that their site remains fast
and delivers great results.
And we think this is a fantastic practice,
so we've added support
for performance budgets
directly to Lighthouse.
Now you can set budgets based on size,
such as total JavaScript download,
or for target metrics like page load time.
And by integrating Lighthouse
with your continuous integration server
you can ensure that your site
stays svelte and healthy.
In addition to making the web faster,
we're also working
to make the web more powerful
and more deeply integrated
with devices and operating systems.
And Google Duo is a great example of this.
It uses the latest features of the web
to support high-quality video calling
right in the browser.
And using WebAssembly,
the team was able to easily bring
their native app features,
like echo detection, to the web.
And because Duo for Web
is a progressive web app,
users can install it across Chrome OS,
macOS, Linux, and Windows,
so it's launchable from a desktop icon
and it runs in its own window.
And we're also seeing companies like Hulu
taking advantage
of these new capabilities
to deliver a powerful, immersive
desktop-app experience
and driving more repeat usage.
And Twitter shows the power
of these progressive web apps
with a single codebase
that scales seamlessly
across a wide variety of devices.
And Twitter and Hulu will actually
be joining us onstage
later today at I/O,
to tell us more about their experiences.
As the web and browsers
continue to evolve,
we know that search engines
need to keep up
in order to understand
how to properly index modern websites
with these latest features.
Today we're announcing
that Google Search is now using
the latest version of Chromium
to index the web.
This means that, as a developer,
you can focus on building your site
using the latest web platform features,
without having to worry
about using hacks or workarounds
to ensure that the Google crawler
properly sees your content.
And you can learn more
on our Webmaster blog,
or at our session here at I/O on Thursday.
User trust and safety is at the heart
of everything we do in Chrome.
It's motivated features
like Safe Browsing,
that protects users from phishing attacks
and malware sites,
and our recent efforts
to move all web traffic to HTTPS.
We believe that giving users
transparency, choice, and control
over how their data is used
and shared on the web
is an important part of these efforts,
and it requires that we all rethink
some of the fundamentals of the web.
Today we're sharing three changes
that we'll start rolling out
later this year.
First, we're changing
how cookies work in Chrome,
making them more private
and secure by default.
Second, we're adding
new features in Chrome
that will build on these cookie changes
to give users more transparency
and easy-to-use controls
over how sites track them across the web.
Third, we're enhancing Chrome
to protect users from techniques
like fingerprinting
that are used to bypass
this user choice and control.
As we work to make the web safer,
we're committed to preserving
the health of the overall web ecosystem
and to working in cooperation
with the broader developer community.
You can learn more
about these upcoming changes
and what they mean for you
on our Chromium blog
and in the "What's New with Chrome
on the Web" session here at I/O.
As the web continues
to evolve at a rapid pace,
we know it can be a little bit tricky
to keep up with the latest features
and best practices.
We created a new website
called web.dev to help.
It's a simple, straightforward guide
to teach you how to build
on the modern web
with interactive code labs
on the most important topics
including how to optimize
popular web frameworks like REACT
for top performance.
Web.dev can help you use
the best of the modern web platform
to create fast, powerful experiences
for your users.
In addition to these platform
and tool changes,
we've also been improving Chrome OS.
In Q4, Chrome OS accounted
for 21% of U.S. notebook sales,
and we expect to see growth continue
as more devices hit the market.
Last year we brought Linux support
to Chromebooks,
and we've continued to integrate this
to provide you with an easy-to-use
Linux development environment
that's fast and safe,
thanks to Google's best-in-class
VM and Sandbox isolation technology.
This integration allows you to do things
like seamlessly share files
across Chrome OS, Google Drive,
Android, and Linux,
and you get all the standard
Linux features,
like port forwarding,
that lets you run your Web server
in the Linux container
and debug on the same machine.
All of this makes Chrome OS
a great choice for developers.
Web developers can code
in a familiar Linux environment
and can test on a variety
of desktop and mobile browsers.
And Android Studio is now available
with a one-click install
and integrated debugging
on any of the Android developer
recommended Chromebooks.
And, finally, we're happy to announce
that all Chromebooks launched this year
will be Linux-ready right out of the box.
(cheers and applause)
And these are just a few
of the most recent improvements
across the web and Chrome OS.
Stay tuned for more features
coming later this year.
Now I'd like to invite Anitha
to talk to you
about machine learning and AI.
(cheers and applause)
♪ (music) ♪
(Anitha Vijayakumar) Thanks, Tal.
Here at Google, we are using AI
to solve a range of challenging problems
to help people in their daily lives.
Whether it is building an AI system
to get rid of 100-million spam messages
each day in Gmail,
or serving relevant and up-to-date content
through Google News
using new AI techniques,
or training a neural network
to improve the way
we interact with our mobile devices
through faster speech recognition
on Gboard,
AI enables us to make our products
more helpful and delightful for our users.
But we want all developers
to be able to build
successful AI-enabled applications
to solve problems.
That is why we built AI tools
that are easy to use right out of the box,
powerful, and flexible,
all available on the platforms
that you care about.
Our tools span from APIs
that are easy to get started with
and come ready
out of the box, like ML Kit,
to more powerful tooling
that gives you the performance you need
like AutoML and cloud TPUs
in the Google Cloud,
and the flexibility to run
powerful AI systems
in production anywhere
with open source libraries
like TensorFlow.
For the millions of Android
and iOS developers,
ML Kits get you started with common
machine learning tasks immediately.
It's taking some of the best features
that power Google's own AI applications
and making them available to you.
Since launching it at I/O last year,
we've seen a lot of adoption
in a wide array of use cases,
like the TextPlus app
which uses SmartReply in-app
to suggest responses,
or the Gradeup app
using text recognition to help students
scan in their homework.
ML Kit's momentum
is why we are excited to share
a couple of new announcements.
First, we are making
AI-powered translation available
through a new on-device translation API.
This new API provides fast,
dynamic translation for 59 languages.
Now, the same machine learning models
that power the Google's Translate app
are available for your app
even when they're offline,
helping to save energy and reduce latency.
Second, ML Kit can help power
your app's visual search experience
with a new object detection
and tracking API.
For retail apps, you can pair this
with Google Cloud's product Search API
to match your product SKUs.
Our partners are already using this API
to build helpful AI experiences
for their users,
like this beautiful IKEA app
which lets you search for products
by just pointing your mobile phone camera.
These are just a few examples
of how ML Kit makes it easy
to integrate AI
into your Android and iOS apps.
You can get started using
these new APIs today through Firebase.
For developers who need more performance
for large machine learning workloads,
Google Cloud provides
a complete set of AI tools,
and this includes AutoML.
AutoML allows you to train
accurate models on your own datasets
without having to write
a single line of code.
And we recently expanded
this product family
to support new use cases,
like the new AutoML Tables
where you can ingest
structured tabular datasets
and generate prediction models
in days instead of weeks.
Now you can take your large CSV files
or database tables
and use them to tackle a range
of challenging problems
such as fraud detection,
optimizing lead conversion,
and predicting user demand.
What's amazing here
is that you can do all of this
with a few clicks, no coding required,
and generate a world-class
machine learning model.
We also launched
AutoML Video Intelligence.
This new service
lets you create custom models
that automatically
classify your video content
with the labels that you define.
So if you deal with a large dataset
and you want to analyze your content
by what is in each frame,
you can create custom labels
and AutoML Video Intelligence
will help you categorize the content
and make it easily searchable.
But to train and deploy your models,
you need powerful computational resources
like cloud TPUs,
our custom AI hardware accelerators.
Through Google Cloud,
our partners have been using
Cloud TPU devices
to accomplish large-scale
machine learning tasks
at incredible speeds.
For example,
Recursion Pharmaceuticals
is using Cloud TPUs
to analyze cellular microscopic images
to help treat rare diseases.
By using cloud TPUs,
they're able to reduce their training time
from 24 hours to nearly 15 minutes.
Today we're announcing
that you can use Cloud TPU V3 pods in beta
on the Google Cloud.
These pods are made up of individual TPUs
and, when assembled together,
you can train models
for image classification,
natural language processing,
and many other ML applications,
scaling up by adding
just two lines of code.
Cloud AutoML and Cloud TPU Pods
are meant to provide you
with the performance you need
to speed up
your machine learning workflow.
We also want to keep you
in complete control
and give you flexibility.
That is why we decided
to open source TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is helping democratize AI
among developers,
businesses, and researchers
by helping them build
truly customized AI experiences.
Since open sourcing it in 2015,
it has matured into a flexible
end-to-end machine learning ecosystem
with a global community.
We recently announced
TensorFlow 2.0 in alpha,
with plans to launch
a release candidate soon.
TensorFlow 2.0 is all about usability.
We are making it even easier
to build and deploy custom models
with more intuitive APIs,
less code needed,
and more flexible
for powerful experimentation
and deployment on the platforms
that you care about.
For JavaScript developers,
TensorFlow.js helps you build,
train, and deploy custom models
right in the browser
and on the Node.js platform.
For developers working
with on-device platforms
such as mobile phones and IoT,
TensorFlow Lite can help you
address common obstacles
in your AI-powered apps
like poor network connectivity,
protecting user privacy,
and low-latency environments,
without sacrificing performance.
In just 18 months,
TensorFlow Lite has been installed
on more than 2 billion devices
including Android, iOS,
and embedded systems.
To demonstrate how fast
and flexible TensorFlow Lite is,
Tim is going to show you custom models,
tracking user movement in real-time
using the GPU on-device.
(Tim Davis) Thanks, Anitha.
We've built a super fun app
called Dance Like
which helps anyone learn
how to be a better dancer
using machine learning.
I'll demo it in a bit, but before I do,
I want to say that making this app
was a lot of hard work
and was only made possible
because of a bunch of teams at Google
but most importantly
because of TensorFlow Lite.
So why was it so tricky?
Well, we set ourselves the goal
of running five intensive,
on-device tasks in parallel, in real-time,
without sacrificing performance.
These tasks were:
running two body-part
segmentation models,
matching the segmentation models,
running dynamic time warping,
playing a video, and encoding a video.
And let me emphasize this again--
all on-device,
simultaneously, in real-time.
To accomplish this,
TensorFlow Lite enables us
to easily delegate acceleration
of our ML models on a GPU.
You can do this on both iOS and Android,
so you have a single framework
for your on-device ML.
Here's a code snippet which shows
how we set up this delegation.
I created a TensorFlow Lite interpreter.
And to execute my model on the GPU,
I just construct a new GPU delegate
and modify the interpreter
to use the GPU delegate, and I'm done.
The models will now run on the GPU.
Now I'm going to do a demo live
and walk you through
the five on-device tasks
running at the same time.
Here we go. Wish me luck!
So there's a few dances
you can choose from.
I'm going to start with slow motion,
because I'm a beginner.
Now, as I fire up my dance moves,
you can see the real-time
segmentation model running on me.
It's segmenting me out from the background
and identifying
all the different parts of my body.
Now, as I follow along the dancer,
a second segmentation model
is now running.
So now there's two segmentation models
running, via the GPU,
to produce a matching score.
The matching score,
up in the top right-hand corner,
is telling me how well
I'm matching the dancer's moves.
How awesome is that, right?
(cheers and applause)
But, wait, there's more!
You know what is really cool?
Using dynamic time warping!
This syncs my slow-motion moves
with my real-time dance.
Pretty fun, right?
You can tell this was
just another day at Google.
Back to you, Anitha.
(Anitha) Isn't that cool? Nice moves, Tim!
(applause)
Whether you are just getting started
with machine learning
or building custom AI apps
like Dance Like,
we want to help every developer
build incredible AI applications,
whatever challenging problems
you are trying to solve.
Now, to talk more about what we are doing
in mobile development,
I'd like to introduce Kristen Johnson.
Thank you.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Thanks, Anitha.
It's great to be here with all of you
to talk a bit about Firebase.
Our mission is to help mobile
and Web app developers,
just like all of you, be successful.
We provide you with a platform
of tools and Cloud services
that simplify your app dev workflows
and infrastructure needs
so you can focus on building
amazing user experiences.
With Firebase, you can build your app
with fully managed back-ends,
improve your app's quality
with testing and monitoring,
and engage your users
with better insights.
As you heard earlier, Google is committed
to making AI available to every developer.
Firebase and ML Kit make it easy for you
to bring machine learning to your apps,
regardless of expertise.
And today we're expanding ML Kit
with the addition of AutoML Vision Edge.
This will simplify the workflow
of building and training
your custom TensorFlow Lite models
to classify images.
All you have to do
is upload a set of images,
click a button to train your model,
and then publish it.
That's it.
Now, once published,
your model is hosted
on Google's infrastructure,
and, with just a few lines of code,
your app can dynamically
retrieve the model and run it on-device.
I'd like to invite
my teammate Stella on stage
to show us how it works.
(Stella Gaitani) Thanks, Kristen.
For this demo, I want to build an app
that identifies different dog breeds.
I will start in the Firebase console
in the ML Kit section
by creating a new dataset
which I will call dog_breeds.
Once my dataset is created,
I just need to add my images.
I will grab my data from my machine,
and I'm going to upload it here.
Now, this can take a little while,
so to speed things up,
I will jump over to this dataset
where I have already uploaded the images.
As you can see, here I can view
all the images I uploaded,
organized by label.
And I can easily add or remove images.
The next step is to train the model.
When training the model,
I can choose how large my model should be
to optimize between latency and accuracy.
And I can also choose
how long to train my model for.
Typically, larger datasets
require longer training times.
For this demo, I will choose eight hours
because my dataset is quite big.
Again, to speed things up,
I'm going to jump over to this dataset
where the model has already been trained.
Once the model finishes training,
Firebase will provide me
with an evaluation
to help me decide if this model
meets my needs
or if I should continue iterating.
I can see the precision and recall rates.
And below these, I have a full breakdown
of how often my model
labeled an image correctly for each label.
The next and final step
is to publish the model.
Once the model is published,
it will be hosted
on Google's infrastructure.
What this means is that I can add
a few lines of code to my app,
and then my app will be able
to dynamically download the model
and do on-device inferencing.
And, now, let's see if this works!
Unfortunately, I couldn't bring
my dog with me on stage,
so we will have to use a stand-in.
Here is our friend.
(laughter)
And I'm going to launch the app
and I'm going to aim a camera
at our friend here.
It's a little harder
with a stuffed animal, but here we go.
You can see that my app in some angles--
This is a border collie, so it can pick up
the border collie right here.
And all of this was done
with just a few lines of code
and a few button clicks.
(applause)
Thanks, Stella.
So that's just one way
that we're expanding Firebase
to simplify app development for you.
Another area that we aim to simplify
is optimizing the performance
of your apps.
Firebase Performance Monitoring
gives you insights
into the start-up time
and network responsiveness
of your iOS and Android apps.
Now we've heard from
all you web developers out there
that you want the same
real user monitoring
that native developers get.
Well, today we're expanding
Performance Monitoring to the web!
(applause)
You heard from Tal
that users want the web to be fast,
which means performance
is a major driver for success on the web.
Tools like Lighthouse are great
for giving you a picture
of how your web app performs
in a targeted, synthetic test.
Now, with Firebase,
you can complement these tools
with an understanding
of how your users are experiencing
your web app out in the wild.
This is awesome,
because it's the first time
that you can see metrics
that are more granular
than just page load time,
like how long it takes users
to see any content on your page
or if the page is ready for interaction.
And you see the full distribution curve
of these metrics
across different countries,
browsers, and network connections.
As an example, I might notice
that load times are slow
for users in a region.
When I investigate further,
I uncover that there is an issue
with a particular CDN point of presence.
Without performance monitoring,
I would not have understood
why my usage was declining in that region.
And all of these insights come
from just a few lines of code.
Firebase Performance Monitoring
for the web is available for free
in beta starting today.
(applause)
And these are just two
of the many exciting updates
we're launching here at I/O for Firebase,
from AutoML Vision Edge
to our new Performance Monitoring
for web apps.
With every improvement to Firebase,
we aim to simplify
your app dev workflows
and infrastructure needs
so that you can stay focused
on building amazing user experiences.
And now I'm going to turn it over to Adam
to wrap things up.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪
Thank you, Kristen.
So I lead Developer Relations,
which gives me
a really unique vantage point.
It's great to connect
with developers every day.
We get to see how all of you
are making web apps, mobile apps,
new AI-driven experiences,
and we get to hear the feedback
that helps us make our products better.
And I'm excited,
because the team has built
a really great I/O for you this year.
We've got sandboxes
where you can see our products in action,
and you'll find everything from AR,
the new serverless cloud offerings
we've released,
and actually an entire sandbox
dedicated to our AI and ML offerings.
Across I/O you'll find more
than 180 technical sessions this year,
all presented by engineering
and product leads.
We've added a new gaming track
that I think you'll really like
with everything from Android,
Cloud gaming, to Stadia,
which is pretty exciting.
And last year, you told us
you liked the inspiration sessions,
so I'm excited to see
some of what we're bringing.
We're bringing even more this year,
and I'm excited to hear
from astronaut Mae Jemison,
Turing Award winner Geoffrey Hinton,
and actually Wayne Coyne,
the lead singer of the Flaming Lips,
is doing an inspiration session.
Who, by the way, The Flaming Lips
are also going to put on
an incredible show tomorrow night.
I'm incredibly excited to see it.
We have a cool AI
musical integration that they've done.
And for everybody watching online,
we're broadcasting it live
so you can watch it too.
(applause)
Now, we have a ton of things
to show you at I/O,
a ton of new technology
that Google is releasing,
and one of my favorites I wanted
to take a minute on is Flutter.
(cheers and applause)
People love Flutter
because it's our open source toolkit
for building iOS and Android mobile apps
from a single codebase.
But we're really pleased
to announce something new today,
and that is a technical preview
of Flutter for the Web.
(cheers and applause)
So now you can take the same code
you would use for mobile devices
and bring it to the web.
So an example of this is
The New York Times,
and The New York Times are doing this
with their puzzle apps.
And rather than rewriting the puzzle app
for every different platform,
they can just write it once with Flutter.
And they can even use Flutter
to take capabilities like this
and add it to their existing apps
and include Flutter technology in it.
So here's an example.
This is KenKen,
one of their number puzzles.
And the game changer here
is they've got the same app
with the same codebase
running at 60 frames per second
on Android, on iOS, on Mac,
on Windows, and now on the web.
It's all compiled automatically,
down in native code or JavaScript.
It's pretty cool stuff.
This is one of the things
we'll be showing.
We'll have this in the Flutter Sandbox.
Check it out today.
(cheers and applause)
So now I wanted to take a second
and talk about
the Google developer community.
All of you are here, we're ten years...
ten years
of our Google developer community
with programs
like Google Developer Groups,
Google Developer Experts,
LaunchPad, Women Techmakers.
(cheers)
You form connections
with developers all over the world,
and I wanted to take a minute
to tell you a story
about one of those developers.
I wanted to tell you a story
about a woman named Nazirini.
Nazirini is a developer from Uganda,
and in that country they're dealing
with a pest in their crops
called fall armyworm,
and it's devastating.
Nazirini is a developer
who got introduced to TensorFlow
through a Study Jam,
and she worked with a team
and used her Android
and her new TensorFlow skills
to build an app
that uses machine learning
to help diagnose and detect
this attack of fall armyworm earlier
to help the farmers treat it
and save their harvest.
Nazirini is actually here today,
and I thought we could
just give her a big hand.
(cheers and applause)
So, as you can see, these connections
you make with the community
really matter, and make
a difference in the world.
Thank you.
Thank you for being
part of this community.
For the meet-ups you host,
for all the feedback you give us,
and all the giving back
and mentoring you do
to other developers, thank you.
And if anyone here is not already
part of one of those communities,
there's absolutely no reason
why you shouldn't join.
And you can join online
with your local group
or you can actually do it here.
We built a really cool
developer Community Lounge
just behind us here
that I think you'll really enjoy
hanging out with.
So then, finally, it's also about
all the connections we have
here at Google with you.
And I'm excited that we have
more than 2,500 Googlers here
to meet with you, to talk with you,
to listen to you, to get your feedback
and share ideas,
and we're incredibly excited to hear
how you're using our platforms.
So with that, I/O is off,
it's off to a great start.
The sessions are about to begin.
Thanks, everyone for coming to I/O.
Have a great time.
(cheers and applause)
♪ (music) ♪